on va passer maintenant blind pièces qui
la séquence finale de cette émission
et pour arbitrer le blind test
j'accueille mal j'avais les cordes
m
cortina messieurs marc philibert et des
donc arbitrer le blind test qui ce soir
est un blind test spécial joujou didier
nicosia si un souffle un julien berdal
bien alors vous connaissez la règle du
jeu c'est pas compliqué donc ça tourne
autour des jouets des joujoux je vous
demande l'interprète
alain chamfort magnifique chanson je
joue à la casse bravo vous êtes une
bonne avocate en plus je sais bien
d'avignon de jolis petits aucune répondu
eh bah oui oui répond pas alors là
alliant il parle en plus on continue
lean
oui
touati
parce que vous nous devez soit toi que
se passe-t-il on continue
oui
des jeunes
ah bon
alors méline alors les voitures en deux
et les poupées en un
d'accord on n'avait pas dit ça mais on
comprend pas toujours bien nous oui
c'est vrai était pas toujours à 10h bon
c'est vrai on continue l'interprète
ici
alors maintenant ils vont le vin
évidemment les disques az c'était chez
europe 1 donc il connaît maintenant
maintenant on va gagner une autre
version de cette chanson
il est
c'est dur c'est christina didier chanson
numéro 5
c
est-ce que ça mérite un petit replay
parce que ça se joue entre le vayer
mariani a pris pressure petit replay
je sais j'en sens numéro six interprètes
risque
c'est génial c'est qui fait chier pour
les rêves mais il est plutôt bon bien
taillé sa barbe à 8,7
paris
le souffle pas le débat
et bon enfant
les mariés j'ai marié s'est marié deux
enfants c est terrible et les trois
délits pris dans les films
morgane c'est vrai c'est vrai 2,5 mal
pour toi qu'est ce que j'ai envie de
passer hier jeudi
c'est jean marie bigard mesdames
messieurs chanson numéro huit viviers
genève
jean marie bigard n'était donc ça fait 3
pour les soupers et 5 pour les voitures
c'est bien je suis d'accord tu es
d'accord
abbas il arbitre je suis d'accord 3 sec
23/100 chasse en numéro 9 c'est dur
dans son énorme et en tee shirt
les vins
charlene a trouvé non archives c'est
celui qui a fait le cheikh khady caraman
regarder la raison puisque c'est thierry
hazard
et maintenant nous arrivons super banco
alors ils vont vous allez voir à quel
point la vie est injuste c'est à dire
que maintenant celui qui gagne l'équipe
ea games est super banco a gagné le
blind test même si les dernières la
première c'est l'injustice de la micro
but symboliser d'une façon
extraordinaire
non c'est da vinci s'est pas fait ça
c'était vraiment pas facile bravo mais
jamal
la méthode est naturellement bon voilà
c'est pas une nouvelle mais donc voilà
donc c'est sylvie joly l'équipe des
petites voitures qui emporte tout merci
à tous
c'était du moment tard
mais pour qui je me prends chez albin
michel le vis de la la la la la la
en tournée dans toute la france
en moins
ben on verra si voix la vidéo n'a manqué
qu'un but the video diamant 390 belchen
voie sanguine verizon milliardaire le
mec
judy la boîte nessakh le 4 juillet
lambert wilson dans le film de jean paul
riopelle en service le 13 juin avec
dieudonné franklin berléand lyon
jackie berroyer les fans des ratings et
qui met en scène de lambert wilson 2
avec kristin scott thomas les 7 8 et 9
juillet pour la 14ème édition des
estivales de perpignan
clara morgane
les responsables à la visionne forest
corp
la gestation
capitaine de l'équipe de france de hand
ball a laissé vide étrange entonnoir
paris jusqu'au 10 juin
à bercy on veut
allez
vice président de la chaîne
parlementaire fruits matin à 8h30 he
added presse sur france musique
ivan levaï au carl rabus liste des mots
chez michel lafon
sharleen spiteri du groupe texas
reste à ses plus grands hits voilà qu'à
semer arrive avec 3i mais vous donc du
verseau
as i lay
c'est le seigneur qui est en promo
sylvie joly c'est lui je dis bravo
et puis je lis je suis madrid aurait
donc engagés mais paris jusqu'au 16 juin
et le cdh évoqué le best-of des 16es de
suivi jolie voilà c'est fait alors je
vais oublier de remercier m à vivoter en
et le plus urgent encore des thierry
mariani gars s'est récusé hors pair du
mont plus voilà et la sortie en vidéo
rd les baies du spectacle de franck
dubosc
je vous ai pas raconté ça existe aussi
en vsl voilà c'était sous mandant parle
l'émission pas comme les autres rendez
vous samedi prochain